notre ami najat vallaud belkacem et
manuel valls veulent nous priver du
débat sur la réforme du collège
ce débat nous devons la voir car il
engage l'avenir de nos enfants ils
engagent l'avenir de la france
décidément avec cette décision les
socialistes nous prouvent qu'ils n'ont
rien compris à la république la
république ce n'est pas le diktat de la
pensée unique la république c'est la
confrontation des idées
ces idées qui le refusent or nous les
républicains nous devons être dans le
combat pour l'école publique
l'école publique qui garantit à chaque
enfant y compris ceux des milieux les
plus populaires d'accéder au savoir et à
la promotion sociale
aujourd'hui en france nous avons des
enfants qui entrent au collège sans
savoir lire sans maîtriser les
fondamentaux
la mission première de l'école ce n'est
pas d'être une garderie où un centre de
loisirs parce que les enfants sans nuire
et la mission première de l'école c'est
d'apprendre à lire à écrire et à compter
nous devons contrôler l'acquisition de
ces savoirs un enfant qui entre au
collège sans savoir lire écrire et
compter ce qui est la base est un enfant
qui est vouée à l'échec
nous ne devons pas laisser cela se
produire
nous sommes les républicains nous devons
nous battre pour ses enfants
et comme
et montesquieu pour faire de grandes
choses il ne faut pas être comme les
socialistes ou dessus du peuple il faut
être avec le peuple
or nous les républicains nous saurons
avec les élèves nous serons avec les
enfants de la république et nous serons
avec leur avenir